they want to go out and they want to
touch they want to vote
i'm working my ass off here i'm soaking
wet already
suppression balls you can't hold them
i'm soaking wet
already suppression falls yesterday we
had three
big ones really big suppression balls
you don't give me the umbrella i'm
soaking wet already
they put numbers you know they're called
suppression suppression balls
they make you like feel badly so you say
to your wife
you said your husband darling let's go
out to dinner and then we'll come back
we love our president
but you know the polls say he can't win
well right now we're leading
in almost everywhere the realm
[Music]
suppression balls by david jones is his
running mate the most liberal senator in
america
kamala
senator kamala harris
democrat kamala
if you have a pre-existing condition
heart disease
diabetes breast cancer their common fear
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank you for
coming for you
if you are under the age senator
[Music]
i want to just first of all say i'm so
excited to be here
thank you thank you thank you there is
so much about what comes out of donald
trump's mouth
don't be rude that is designed to
distract the american people
from what he is doing every day that is
about neglect
negligence and harmony you are fake news
don't be rude the name of jesus from
south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
they're coming here from africa
i hear the sound of victory
[Music]
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of winning winning
winning winning winning
[Music]
should i play this this is one of the
most vile callers we have
take a listen to the i have not
pre-screened this so i let me just warn
you
this may not be all right things started
very quickly and joe biden is already
sitting and about to get his vaccine so
let's go there first
because we don't want to miss that that
key moment a lot of crazy things going
on
i'm going to talk about the problem the
biden camp is having with scheduling in
a moment
um but here is joseph r biden jr about
to get himself
a coronavirus vaccine dose number one
we're going to look in a moment at
how many people have gotten the vaccine
so far how many vaccines have been sent
out
i may take some phone calls from it the
scheduling is insane what's going on
for a week they say sometime today
biden's getting the vaccine
and 20 minutes ago they say biden's on
route right now
after all day saying we don't know when
we don't know where
um so in any case here is joe biden
i'm ready okay ready to go okay let's
listen
oh his arms hairier than i would have
expected that's interesting
no no you just go ahead anytime you're
ready
and here it is
i don't care if you give me a band-aid
okay look what i want to say is we owe
these folks an awful lot
the scientists and the people who
put this together the front-line workers
the people who
were the ones who actually did the
clinical work
are just amazing and i wish we had time
to take you through the whole hospital
to see how busy and incredible you all
are
and we owe you big we really do
and one of the things is that i think
that
the administration deserves some credit
getting us off the ground
operational warp speed i also think that
it's worth saying that this is there's
great hope
of doing this to demonstrate that people
should be prepared when it's
available to take the vaccine right
there's nothing to worry about
i'm looking forward to the second shot
so is jill she's had her shot
earlier today she loves shots i know
i've had so many look at biden relating
normally to people
my next visit and uh but the important
thing is that it's worth stating that uh
you know this is just the beginning it's
one thing to get the vaccine
out and now modernity is uh
is is going to be on the road as well
but it's going to take time it's going
to take time
in the meantime i know i don't want to
sound like a cellar note here but uh
so i hope people listen to all the
experts from the dr fauci is on
talking about the need to wear masks
during this
christmas and new year's holidays wear
masks socially distanced
and uh and if you don't have to travel
don't travel
right don't travel it's really important
because we're still in the thick of this
it's one thing to have a vaccine show up
at a hospital
there's another thing to get the vaccine
from that vial
into a needle into an arm and
there's millions of people out there
that are going to need this
front line workers first but i just want
to thank everyone
for all that they've done you some real
heroes
some real heroes and you're among them
thank you
biden getting his i've been vaccinated
sticker
and a fist bump with the nurse
and joe biden continuing to relate to
people in a normal way
which is something we don't uh we we
don't often see well we're gonna get to
that later
uh let's see what else is going i don't
even know what uh what other streams we
have this stream is still
live but but frozen um and we're going
to get to a bunch of other things here
momentarily
wow very powerful moment
as you can see uh the camera person so
overcome with the motion from
vaccination starting that they're
filming the floor as you can see
okay we have another stream over here
from cbs and
it looks like that event uh is over now
i don't know how many of you guys know
this
but there's also an event uh turning
point usa
live and we're expecting dave rubin and
senator ted cruz and others
right now we have um we have eric
balling who is there
i see so many questions coming in about
am i going to be talking about the
coronavirus stimulus yes
already recorded a segment segment goes
live later today from the podcast
and on youtube am i going to be talking
about left in fighting
between ayoke and jimmy dore and others
yes segment now that i know about it
segment
on that on today's podcast am i going to
be talking about donald trump
uh considering martial law and the
seizure of voting machines
yes segment about that as well we have
segments on all of these elements
already planned
but before we get to any of that i have
so many things to go over and to play
for you
um david haldane has sent a beautiful
super chat and says wait the vaccine
doesn't come with a windows boot up
noise
it is surprising it is surprising but
it does not uh interestingly enough
um i do want to say a big thank you to
michael carlisle
who just signed up at joinedpakman.com
and is new member number one
uh and also want to say thanks to the
three people
who have signed up uh via twitch as well
okay so very exciting let's take a quick
listen to toilet paper usa
and a question being asked all right so
i have a lot of friends who i would
consider moderate
and i understand that they could become
great
uh you know conservatives
and most of them they are like uh
they're pro 2a
so what should i show them so they can
fully commit
to conservatism and see what we really
are and what we truly believe
i think i think the best way to deal
with the question is what what can you
show a moderate to
to bring him over to the to the right
sean why why
it's important why the second amendment
is important just just have them listen
to what every
anything that comes out of the squad's
mouth elon omar aoc's mouth
uh ayano presley and uh rashida talib
everything they say is communist so
basically he has nothing to offer that
would be convincing so he's saying
listen to other people and hope that
they're turned off by the other side
so that's really really weird weird
stuff uh but we're gonna we're gonna
keep an eye on that and
should any arbiters of ideas speak we
will certainly
uh take a look okay in terms of vaccine
numbers what's going on so far
okay 556
000 shots have been administered
nationally
so far and you can look at numbers by
state here there have been about 3
million doses allotted so far
and about half a million update
administered as of yesterday okay so
we're these numbers are going to
continue to update
and we are going to keep those uh very
very much
uh uh viewable and and present we also
have numbers that are looking pretty bad
which is that a lot of people
continue to die of coronavirus now we
did have a weekend anytime there's a
weekend you start to see
a bit of a downturn now my i've said
this before
my expectation is that the uh
peak the what should be the final spike
should be around mid-january at that
point you will have the effect
of the upcoming christmas and
end-of-year gatherings which will be
disastrous
and you will start rounding that peak
and we will have increased vaccination
so my
expectation is that we are going to see
another little spike
uh up until about january 8 9 10 and
that will start to decline
and then deaths which trail cases by
three weeks
will probably max out at the end of
january and then again
assuming nothing goes wrong with
vaccination distribution or any of these
things
we will start to see what will hopefully
be a permanent decline
um at that point in time that's what
we're looking at
um right now and of course
many variables and and all of that uh
remains to be seen
bae photo says do via super chat do we
know if biden got the fuckizer or
moderna vaccine
i don't know and i don't believe that
it's been said um
if anybody has any other information
about that uh certainly
certainly let me know so we're keeping
an eye on that
also i wanted to take a look with you
here there is this a clip that our
friend aaron rupar
said is one of the dumbest things he's
ever seen on fox news
that's interesting to me so let's take a
listen to it together
really what are the rules to the speaker
of the house and do any of them
include things that cost oh i don't know
a whole lot less than that freezer full
of ice cream and i don't mean to be so
petty about it
but imagine if you could liquidate that
in dollars and add that to the to the
weekly stimulus check
so you take um a hundred and fifty
dollars worth of nancy pelosi's ice
cream
150 dollars divided by
uh what is it about um 200 million
americans who will qualify for six
hundred dollars
what's 150 bucks divided into 200
million americans does anybody know is
that a fraction of a penny
that is pretty damn stupid that is very
very stupid yeah
i think i think aaron is completely
right uh oh what am i drinking yeah this
is so i've been
in the afternoons i've been making a
dirty chai
lately this is a great drink it's chai
tea you brew chai
tea normally and then you add a shot of
espresso to it it could be decaf
espresso
it could be calf it could be half calf
it could be two-thirds calf
i can dial it in however i want and then
a little bit of cow's milk
and then it's a hell of a drink it is an
absolutely fantastic fantastic drink
dirty chai
is what uh what the kids call it this
day very good really easy
that's all it is you just need a grinder
an espresso machine
a water boiler
tea coffee beans milk
um you know it only requires like seven
to ten
seven to ten different things okay so
now that we've gotten that out of the
way
badger wants to know if i'm aware of the
new coveted strain in the uk i am aware
of it
yeah so it's important that when we talk
about the new covet strain
we distinguish between the things we
know and the things we don't know
we know that the covet strain that is
taking over in the uk
spreads much more easily um it's
believed to have an r
naught of about .4 higher than the
previous
strains uh what we don't have any
evidence for is that it's deadlier
or we don't even know whether it may be
less deadly we just don't know often
with viruses as they become more
transmissible they become less deadly
that's something you can look at
historically and we don't know
all we know is it's more transmissible
so we don't and and there's no reason at
this point to believe that it is more
deadly no reason to believe that the
vaccine
will be uh affected in any way by it so
that that's what we know
at the time uh currently okay um
all right other things going on oh i do
have voicemail
actually let's see so first of all
i have a few space force what do you
guys want to do first
do you want creationist cat video
about the david pakman show do you want
space farce
related memes and songs do you want troy
york voicemails
or do you want repeater voicemails
i'm not doing a poll or anything i'm
just asking and you can tell me what
what you prefer um
a lot of creationist cat
people want repeater paula white
spit cat sounds injury okay people are
liking cat okay let's get to that
a producer pat sent this to me now i was
on this show called the creationist cat
show
a while ago i think it's been years i
don't actually remember
seeing this intro but based on the uh
the way in which my character has been
assailed lately this actually is pretty
damn funny so let's take a look at it
together this is pretty good
his name is david hackman political
commentator
left-wing propagandist master of fake
news
an heir to the pac-man family fortune
he gets money from george soros to
promote communications
anti-fall and uh probably baby punching
too
and he's here today to spread more of
his
anti-american freedom-hating
shy-by-lines
[Music]
wow this is aggressive yo yo yo jay
pacma show if you like fake news
he's your pro satan has some communism
and current events too
from his argentinians showing you
donald trump's about all he do should
get ready pacquiao
oh my god
[Music]
yeah buy crash's cat t-shirt
that is so amazingly good and accurate
that
i don't know how we would be able to
continue without that as our
theme song and i i'll our attorney will
get in touch to negotiate terms with you
i mean that's just amazing
yep so there it is i i've never i don't
remember seeing that before like maybe i
saw that when that show aired
years ago maybe not i don't remember um
okay we have a panel now
happening at the turning point usa event
it's a panel
i think it's a panel of conservative
women let's take a brief listen
campuses to the world into the media i
absolutely love it
today we are going to be talking to
three women who are really smashing
i don't recognize any of these people
women have to be leftists that they have
to be
pro-abortion that they have to hate guns
that they have to hate freedom of speech
and instead they're paving a new path
for conservative voices in congress
it is such an honor to be sitting here
with these incredible women these are
members of congress a chance to
introduce yourself
patriots hello
it is so great to be here with you guys
uh this has been an extraordinary
weekend
and your energy is incredible
do not lose this passion i can tell you
you can have all the policy experience
in the world but without passion without
a desire
to want to keep america the greatest
most exceptional country in this world
oh my god
you won't get it done did she say her
name
now i'm not a politician well who are
you fed up with politicians
i'm a mom i have four boys
[Applause]
i am raising my four boys to be men
i am raising my four boys to have
america
this is vomitous okay so we're going to
turn that down for now we're get we're
continuing to monitor this event
everybody just stay as calm as possible
we'll keep monitoring it there's a lot
of screaming going on
and i know that there's this idea i know
somebody will write to me and say david
you're only saying they're screaming
because they're women that's
misogynistic
no i i identified screaming by men at uh
a number of different right-wing events
so it's not it's not a gender-based
based thing i just
there's a lot of screaming at a lot of
these right-wing events it's very weird
um douglas blackwell wants to know would
the military have to follow trump in
attempting a coup
yeah i don't know how trump does it
without without the military involved to
some degree that's a fair point
i want some heavy metal guitar drums
bass in the songs please love your show
david thanks dustin
i appreciate that okay now we've gotten
what do
so we've gotten some elements out of the
way do you want neck actually you know
what let's do space farce next
okay i don't know how many of you saw
this with us the other day
but there was a giga cringe moment when
mike pence announced
that we will now have uh soldiers
marines airmen
sailors and and and and
guardians okay some of you will remember
this from last week
as i mentioned we just returned from the
oval office and so
it is my honor on behalf of the
president of the united states
to announce that henceforth the men
and women of the united states space
force will be known
as guardians
oh no
no it can't be
the guardians of the galaxy
oh my god kill me
it can't be it can't be
anyway so that was really bad and i got
a bunch of different things from people
i got this space force meme which is me
and trump i guess this is me
as leonard nimoy and uh trump
as captain kirk right bill shatner
is that was is that accurate here
trump's stupid face
space farce i like this this is nicely
done
um so that's uh that's pretty good but
then i also received
from our friend jethro bradley a
new track called the space farce
guardians which i'm going to debut for
you right now okay let's take a listen
to it
the men and women of the united states
space force
will be known as guardians
oh no
[Applause]
no it can't be it's already
from our president a man who is actually
in space
right now space farce
[Music]
comes to the outer reaches of space you
are that strength
if you rise on the wings of the dawn if
you settle
on the far side of the sea even if you
go
up to the heavens it's even cringe like
this
[Music]
and his right hand will hold you fast to
defend america
and defend our freedom from space space
guardians god bless our guardians
[Music]
so i think you guys get the get the idea
so that is uh that is that that's a new
track and that's exciting stuff
so let's see we took it we did vaccine
tracker
we did uh the cringe we did
the fox news clip all right i always
have things planned so i'm just going
through here and making sure we're
hitting
everything let me do let me do a couple
of super chats
actually let me do a couple thank yous
then i'll do super chats then we'll get
to voicemails because we do have
we do have some pretty aggressive stuff
zach mayfield is new member number five
today
and patrick mcdonough is new member
number six at join pacman.com
we also just had an additional seven
folks
grab twitch subs which puts us at 13.
okay i have a plethora
of voicemails from re peter
and i also have three voicemails
from troy york do we want re-peter
or do we want troy york first this will
just be very informal i'll go by what i
see happening
uh in chat but i'm going to get to some
super chats
momentarily here it looks pretty split
between repeater and troy
if i mentioned that two of the
voicemails are troy playing characters
would that change the calculus at all
oh repeater is blowing it out of the
water
repeater okay all right so we'll go to
repeater first very good okay
a couple of um a couple of other super
chats jared says david having a live
stream at the same time as the daily
show goes live should be as illegal as
your membership discount codes aloha i
agree with that
sunil mahwani says barr says there's no
need for hunter special counsel
is that stupid investigation out of
oxygen or still something to worry about
i wouldn't be shocked to see republicans
demand hunter biden hearings
consider remember when benghazi happened
and four people tragically died
but hillary clinton did nothing criminal
obviously and they had 11 hearings
thanks to trump's incompetence we've now
had more than 300 000 people die of the
virus of course
many people would have died regardless
of trump's response but many who didn't
have to die died
and we've had zero investigative
hearings
so far that look at the criminal
mishandling of the virus
by donald trump it's incredible um
okay cb says any updates on the cyber
situation i heard trump put baron on the
case
and that blamed it all on china no i
mean it is incredible what baron's doing
with computers these days
but uh apparently trump is not not
putting
baron on that all right let's get into
the voicemails
we introduced a new voicemail caller
two weeks ago known as re
peter because he calls in and just
repeats repeats repeats we even have a
song about repeater take a look
[Music]
i have no name for this caller we could
workshop a name together
okay here we go so this started almost
at the stroke of midnight last night
all right let's take a listen to the
first one this is a new caller we've
never had this one before
new caller alert is this david pac-man
i just want to inform you that is this
david pac-man
i just want to inform you that you are a
idiot
idiot once again i'm going to say it
again we now have
evidence that one of the voting machines
in one of the counties in georgia okay
anyway so
at this point at last stream
that i had where we were together i had
received
21 voicemails from this gentleman over
uh the last 24 hours
i received 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14
14 more now obviously i'm not going to
spend the next hour just playing these
for you that would be really a problem
um
but let's just listen to a couple he had
a new topic but um
14 more voicemails okay let's take a
listen this is re
peter you know you are
truly david the gossip show
now you're talking about this virus let
me explain
so now he's on the virus the virus i
think to you because you really
are one of the dumbest human beings i've
ever seen
when it comes to mask a cloth mask
will not stop a virus it won't
and when you take the number of people
that have passed away
from the virus with a total number of
people who actually get it
you have a 99 listen to this i don't
know i don't think you'll get it because
you're not smart enough
okay so that's voice i i'm going to just
do a an overview because there's so many
of these this one was 108 in the morning
david the gossip show i'm calling about
you're talking about this virus listen
to me very carefully you're not going to
understand this because you don't
you're just not that smart so he repeats
the same thing next call is 2 17 a.m
here we go david the gossip show listen
to me very carefully this is about the
coving
okay 99 of the people who get it survive
it
okay that means you only have one
percent of people that get it
that don't survive it okay are you guys
able to remember the number is it 98
because he keeps calling and reminding
me but i keep forgetting is it 98
that survive is that the number i just
keep forgetting so quickly
let's go to his next voicemail from 2 59
a.m
i'm going to repeat myself again david
the gossip cell
and like i said david you act like a
little girl you you belong in a dress
and then with some lipstick on it high
heels
the corona virus okay it's actually from
china it's actually the china virus
that's worked because that's where it
came from
anyways 99 of the people who get
the corona virus for coronavirus
survives it let me all right uh
voicemail number five
six i don't know this is for david the
gossip show
about the coronavirus 99
of the people who get the virus survives
the virus
okay he did three minutes on that and
then call call number seven eight i
don't know
i'll say it one more time david about
the coronavirus
99 of the people who get the corona
virus
they survive the coronavirus that means
just a little over one percent of the
people who get it
don't survive the body i'm really
struggling with that math okay next call
david the gossip show this is real
simple
yeah we have forensic proof
that these dominion machines okay so now
he's moving on to something else
do uh certain things to flip votes
to weigh votes and they're designed to
they're weighing them you have
the forensic evidence now we already
all right so by voicemail 10 he's on
dominion
these dominion machines we have forensic
evidence okay and he goes on now what's
interesting is after a couple of more
he took how long of a break was this he
took a two and a half hour break
between calls now let's i wonder what
happened during those two and a half
hours let's see what happened
after the break hey david some girl that
i grew up with
one of my best friends of all times i've
known
i've known this girl over 30 years
she said that she has some hot a couple
pairs of high heel
shoes okay and a few dresses that would
fit you
uh that i can send to you for christmas
it's i mean so first of all i'm jewish
so i don't accept christmas gifts i only
accept hanukkah gifts but you know it's
like if i needed high heels i could
borrow my girlfriend's high heels it's
just
it's weird why would this you think i
need this guy to send me high heels
here's one more
oh i just wanted to repeat uh something
that i
said the idea that he has to let me know
he'll be repeating content is pretty
pretty pretty full on
in the last message that i sent you a
wonderful girl that i grew up with
a sweetheart that i've known over 30
years
she said um she told me
that she has a couple of pair a couple
pairs of high heel
shoes and a couple of dresses that
she would love to give to you for
christmas it's weird because as if i
didn't get that in the previous
voicemail and then here's the absolute
last one of the night
this one coming four hours after the
first call
oh david i forgot to tell you this
wonderful
girl that i know that i've known for
over 30 years
she said that she will send you some
high heels
and a few dresses that will you know
that would probably fit you
and okay well that is different none of
my girlfriend's stuff would fit me if
this
if this friend of his wears the same
size shoe as me and same size dress i
guess that would be something
that she will send you some lipstick as
well
okay that to match the dresses i mean
maybe i just accept it what do you think
guys if she's insisting on sending me
this stuff maybe i just go for it
okay big thank you to muad alamari whose
new member number 14
today and stephen cole who's member
number
15. i do appreciate that also big thank
you to moon metal
uh and juiceman anonymous gifter
zindragon funky pug stefan rowe
lerkly gerrymandering and a lot of other
great people who have supported
via twitch i appreciate that okay so
that is re
peter re peter calling in we are
continuing to monitor turning point usa
this is a really strong panel i guess
these women are
incoming members of congress i don't
know who any of these people are but
let's take a listen
my team my staff my interns people that
i have worked with over the years
they have said i have been intimidated
on campus i have
done things that i i feel go against my
beliefs
to get a grade don't back down
and if you have a professor that is
intimidating you
i will pledge to you right now i will
come to your class
i will happily speak and i will debate
any college professor
that asks for it that's really weird
like any college professor
see this is one of the problems that
exists with with these right-wing
lunatics
which is that i'll so it's the same
how can i let me see if i can string
this together i haven't really thought
about how to kind of frame this
you know one of the laughable things
that happened in the
um last couple weeks is that people with
no college degree
started evaluating the merits of dr
jill biden's uh doctorate dissertation
and and people who have never been to
college or people with a bachelor's
degree
in something completely unrelated to
education random bloggers
everybody's evaluating the merits of dr
jill biden's doctorate thesis
right and that's the same sort of
uh you know delusion
that exists when someone like this says
i'll debate
any professor well what do you mean
debate any professor
you'll debate like an astronomy
professor about
what you'll you'll debate a uh
a chemical engineering professor about
their like what is it what
and i know that i i'm what she's
implying is i guess she'll debate
professors about
politics or or something but it's it's
this
arrogance and perspective that has
become
viral it's a mind virus on the right
about listen people you just learn
opinions in college
people with opinions professors give the
students opinions and everything is just
subject to to opinion
um and yet science is liberal rather
than an empirical process
and all it it's really really and there
is a dunning-kruger aspect i like that
people in the chat are pointing out that
there's a dunning-kruger aspect where
they so misunderstand the difference
between
an opinion about abortion and
empiricism and the scientific method
that
they don't even recognize that they lack
the capacity to even understand what
sorts of things are being done
in college and they think it's all just
liberal nonsense i can show up and
debate anybody
um it's it's it's pretty person and it
is people who have no right to be
arrogant about anything as uh
as betty veronica is pointing out in in
twitch chat
okay let's do a couple other super chats
and then i'm going to
um get to the troy york voicemails i did
promise to get that
lannis says is that a solid gold dancer
hosting this event i don't know what
that is i don't know what that is
is that a strip club or something solid
gold i know that there used to be a gold
club in palmer massachusetts
closed very very strongly um but
uh in any case i don't really know what
that is let's listen to a little bit
more of this and then we'll get to the
troy york
voicemails afraid to fail i'm not afraid
for someone to tell me no i'm afraid to
not have those opportunities
and if this turns into a socialist
nation oh my god
that's where we'll be we won't have
those opportunities
how would it how would it turn into a
socialist nation where there's no
socialists in power
would be tough hanging out in in the
hallways with you and hearing your
stories of why you're here and why
you're motivated
you know i was raised in a democrat home
my mom believed the lies of the democrat
party
they sounded real good to her it sounded
really good to say
vote for me and we'll feed your children
if you don't vote for me the other guy
wins and you live under a bridge
so i know what it's like to to trust in
and wait for those government handouts
and that's a cycle of poverty
that they want you stuck in there's no
incentive to get out of that
i stood in line at 11 years old for
bread
and cheese that's not the american dream
what line
what is she talking about and that's
what i'm here
to fight to make sure i mean i stood in
line for cheese today i just i was just
waiting at the checkout line it's sort
of absent context it's kind of a
meaningless comment
a poor democrat dependent on government
but i took a stand
i put my hand to something i started
working i've never seen such a strong
attack on grocery lines i mean listen if
you want to up the number of cashiers
i'm all for that last thing i want to do
is wait in line the american dream that
i can do that
so all of this starts with standing your
ground you have the same
rights that everyone else on the left
has use them who's saying they don't
it's it's non-sequitur after straw man
after red herring
add something to that if you are going
to resolve to stand up and speak
up you also need to get in your mind
that you may suffer
you might suffer loss you may now i have
to tell you
the the right is smart to do this
because so like what do we have on the
left
they are taking they are taking college
age people
and indoctrinating them into
non-thinking mind virus lunacy
but it's well funded they bring on you
know
blonde female young hosts before they
had another one and another one and
another one
they actually are are uh getting a lot
of mileage out of putting money into
this stuff on the left we've got like
okay we've got netroots nation
which i've been too many times and like
it's okay but it's not
it's not well produced like this um
there's left forum which you know i love
a lot of a lot of friends that
participate at left forum i've done some
panels there
but it is a [ __ ] show i mean left forum
the organ is it's insane the stuff that
goes on at left forum
so they they are really i mean this is
sort of like the perfect combination of
politics as sport with
celebrity culture and uh
you know just like finding attractive
women to to
give messages and the left is just not
good at this stuff
and to the extent that this works right
now
the left is failing at this type of
thing there's there's no there's no
question about i think we need to
recognize that if we don't
if we don't at least acknowledge that to
some degree um
i i think you know we don't have to
acknowledge it and then do it
but at least we need to acknowledge it
and say how do we fight this stuff
because this stuff is really effective
um in in a lot of ways and and part of
it is um appealing to shallowness for
sure shallowness of argument
and shallowness of personality and
shallowness of culture yes
absolutely but the point is uh does it
work
does it work and i believe that to a
great degree it does college i mean i
like lauren i grew up in a democrat
family i think there's been this
narrative out there
and it's not even political it's this
notion that
things have always been done this way so
we're going to keep doing them that way
right
but that's the definition of insanity
and i saw it firsthand in 2016 when i
was out campaigning for president trump
i got called a traitor more times than i
can count and i know i'm a blonde so i
probably can't count that high but
you know oh this is so stupid okay a
couple of other super chats matt chavez
says 80 000 more deaths the us will
surpass
world war ii death it will almost
certainly happen i imagine
a big thank you to ronyan one who has
now been an eight month
subscriber on twitch who says of all the
gossip shows i watch
yours is the greatest according to many
people
have a happy hanukkah thank you hanukkah
is over but i am still taking a
posthumous uh hanukkah congratulations i
i appreciate that okay um am i
opening phone lines i i don't know i
mean we have a goal of a hundred
to open phone lines
we kind of got caught off guard with
this stream and we weren't able to
properly build it up
so let's just say let's do this let's
make the goal 50 okay i've just halved
the goal which puts us twice as close
if we get to 50 website members and
twitch subs i will open up the phone
lines and of course the coupon code is
fresh start for 70 percent off
at uh joinpakman.com let's get to the
troy york
of voicemails okay i have three troy
york voicemails
troy york is a guy who calls in he's
from the
midwest he he accidentally doxed himself
a few weeks ago so we know who he is now
um but uh so he called in with
uh first he called in with his black
character who is jamal
jenkins that's his black character then
he called in as troy york
and then he called in with a new
character who i guess is british and his
name is
whitaker marshall iii uh let's go in
chronological order here is troy york
calling in as jamal
jenkins first and foremost this is jim
flip officer jamal jenkins
from university park governor state
university
in illinois and uh i'm just uh listening
to your program you
you talk about the coven numbers and and
how a disaster it is
and uh about how we have so much cases
and you won't shut up about covid
so many cases like you all
basically don't realize that the health
industrial complex
and the socialists within it
and the globalists uh like yourself have
the globalist is code for jew by the way
the health industrial complex is not
doing well with this
if you look at second quarter gdp the
biggest
drag on gdp in the second quarter was
healthcare
it's healthcare that is most affected i
have friends who are doctors and nurses
who have gotten a 15 pay cut and are
working 15
fewer hours um the the profit
in medicine i'm against that this is i'm
against this being the paradigm but
the profit is in things like uh
necessary
but but optional but not not emergency
necessary but non-emergency things like
hip replacements as an example you could
do it now you could do it later
back surgeries those are the things that
have been
for a while shut down and then now very
spaced out
in much of the country so the idea that
the health industrial complex likes this
is really dumb
as far as socialists and globalists
those are dog whistles including
anti-semitic ones various plans for our
country
our culture and our academy and this
covered
media over reporting overstating false
numbers
keep hyping it up so the evidence is the
numbers are understated not overstated
it's basically a conspiracy to
demoralize this country
try to push it towards a path of
socialism and big government
that's you know what's funny about these
socialism conspiracy theories is
like at some point don't you need some
socialists in power
if this is all a big game to and by the
way
is the virus from china or is it the
american health industrial complex that
is doing the virus
it that that's you know he always also
calls and says it's china
um at some point if this is all a cover
to install socialism um
then you need some socialists in power
and we have none in the united states
uh you are a fraud you never debate
anyone i
i challenge you to have an anthony brian
logan
again he this guy always tells me to
debate people who i have never heard of
anthony brian logan i don't know who
that is i know brian tyler cohen
or uh officer tatum
officer tatum officer tate
my god
are tyrone magnus or mark dice or
mark dice i know because he once
attacked me publicly
there's so many right-wing conservatives
on youtube
who made great points and point out the
hypocrisy of the
people like you and the left and
you i would debate andrew dice clay that
would be interesting okay so that was
voicemail number one as jamal jenkins
but about 20 of the way in troy york
forgot he was supposed to be jamal
jenkins
then troll york calls in again yes david
i would want to call
him say that 90 99 of people
accusing donald trump of being a
narcissist
are narcissists themselves hypocrites
people like yourself you run a podcast
why don't you quit wait a second
i'm a narcissist and a hypocrite because
i haven't
quit my podcast what recorded and
take some money and stuff oh the money
thing again
guys listen i haven't gotten a penny in
stimulus money
i've got nothing personally i took no
ppp
no pp or ppp or ppe
i've taken none of it um and
i took no eidl i mean i got and with the
second stimulus i'm getting nothing i
had people emailing me
saying um david you're you're you're
calling for a bigger
stimulus because you want more money i'm
not getting any money from it
this is not for me i know this might be
a hard thing for some people to
understand but
i'm thinking of other people i'm not
getting any money
i'm not getting any money from any of
this stuff well the uh
media wing why don't you pay more taxes
okay again me sending in more taxes is
not
you know it's not it first of all you
can't and in in certain states you can
pay
like in massachusetts says you know the
tax rate is 5.1
if you want you can pay i think it's 5.5
uh
me paying more would not be policy and
federally i'm pretty sure if you send in
more taxes
they send it back it's called a tax
refund if you overpay it's not policy
anyway
you are one of the biggest narcissists
there is and
all these people in the mainstream media
we call donald trump and narcissist all
right so this one's pretty boring and
then lastly
here's troy york debuting a new
character i guess this is supposed to be
a british accent
it's weird and the character is
whittaker marshall the third
hello david this is whitaker marshall
the third uh just calling to
ask one question i'm just seeing boris
johnson
walking down great britain and his
demands too
i don't know why someone would call me
to ask about boris johnson
who's the leader in another country from
a party that is not aligned with my
politics like i have nothing i have no
idea
who who am i to to defend or
say anything about what boris johnson's
doing and christmas
and along with government it's funny how
troy york within 15 seconds forgets the
character he's playing
and now he's back to his american accent
the double chinese twin of the
mainstream
corporate media what is it what is a
hatred and obsession with trying to
cancel christmas and i was wondering you
as a liberal
if you can explain what this hatred of
christmas
is listen i'm jewish i don't care about
christmas
what i do know is it seems to be
happening every time i go
i go into cvs and there's christmas
music playing
the trash collectors now are wearing
santa hats
they were never wearing yarmulkas during
hanukkah they were they're wearing santa
hats
okay um what
who it's very weird
and i'm just wondering uh is that
something to do with the media
being run by jews ah
there it is there it is so we're gonna
close out
uh that actually seems to be right i
must be against christmas
because i'm jewish that would be it okay
big thank you to andrew schumann
who is new member number 16 today at
joinpackman.com
and also a big thank you to the 14
additional twitch prime subscribers
because today's stream was kind of
haphazardly put together
we reduced our goal from 100 to 50
so i will open phone lines if we get to
50
website members and twitch subscribers
now i want to warn people
it's possible that on january 20th
our membership discounts will no longer
be allowed
okay so this is a perfect time to take
advantage of the coupon code fresh start
at joinpakman.com let's see what's going
on here it seems like things are getting
crazy
[Applause]
yes
so i really appreciate that i'm gonna
put that on speaker and on repeat four
all right everybody these three ladies
are just getting started with their
journey in representing the conservative
movement we're
so grateful for the leadership that
they've already expressed
and let's give them a big cheer as they
head on to washington
dear god
what an event okay now i guess they move
the chairs around pretty big time super
spreader event happening there
uh for sure okay other super chats
coming in
do i think trump will ban flights from
the uk over the new covet strain
i think trump is checked out i mean
maybe he will maybe he won't
he's not been seen in public for weeks
and he has nothing on his schedule ever
so i don't i don't know that trump's
gonna do anything
owen says so is the noun democrat an
adjective now they just say democrat
city democrat family without realizing
how uneducated it sounds yes that's
exactly what they do
john henson says you said hanukkah was
over but someone came to me and said
sir it's not over and you have made it
better than ever fake news david gossip
news
okay um chaka seki says david could you
set up a voicemail debate between re
peter and troy york yes troy if you're
listening please call in and comment
about what re peter is saying
and re peter if you're listening please
come in and comment about what troy york
is saying i think that that would be
great
let's listen to alex marlow of breitbart
news
thank you thank you
uh it is a thrill to be with you a
turning point it's actually a thrill to
be in a room with other human beings
which super spreader my buddy dave
reuben who's next up after me
oh god we were both talking yeah dave's
a great guy
neither of us have given a speech since
last year's turning point usa summit
which i'm sure is
the student action summit from last year
uh and
i was thinking about this when i saw sas
was coming back
i reached out to my buddy charlie who
i've known for many many years i think
we
who did he say is coming back sas shut
up
and i said i can't believe it you guys
are doing sass that's so cool i'd love
to be a part of it
where is it going to be and he said to
me well why don't you take a guess where
it's going to be
i said oh i like games that's fun so i
thought about where all the places they
could have a gathering like this so my
first thought was with charlie's chicago
guys maybe illinois
no no lock down there democrat governors
and all
how about new york
so what's going on in new york right now
you might have noticed that there's no
indoor dining but you can
go in a tent outdoors that's completely
closed off
and has lights on and very little
ventilation
and it's freezing yeah that's stupid i'm
against that you're basically indoors at
that point
i've seen where it's like it's
completely it's it's a tent outside on
the sidewalk
that's sealed with a heater it's like
you're basically inside at that point
it's going to be in california but not
just california it's going to be in
napa at the french laundry right
yeah yeah
so those of you who don't know the story
most of you do the government well yeah
this is really really dumb
okay so we can't we're not going to be
able to do too much more of that
a thanks to nathan cofrin who's new
member number 31 today
at joinpacman.com also big thank you to
magnum satan for gifting some subs
um there are looks like a total of three
more there
which puts us at 34. we may actually get
the phone lines open that would be
interesting
um i would be interested in in hearing
from some folks okay
so we did the troy york voicemails
we did the repeater voicemails
um did i have anything else as far oh
people asking about joe biden
getting the uh vaccine yeah so it
happened earlier
let's see um if we can find the video of
it
uh biden vaccine just so you guys can
see the big moment
here it is let's take a look at it in
case you missed it
okay to get the injections
we'll move up a little bit here we go
very very exciting moment
are you awful busy haven't you oh
incredible
she's from cameroon
i guess you need everybody watching
actually like this nurse's technique i
thought it was very smooth
all right little alcohol swab
schwab as some call it no no you just go
ahead anytime you're ready
and there it is
joe biden receiving his first dose
remember the first dose believed to get
you by
day 21 on which you need the second dose
somewhere between 60 and 75 percent
likelihood of immunity
um and then that second dose upping it
to about
uh 95 so that was earlier joe biden
receiving the first dose of the
coronavirus vaccine
um rising phoenix says would have been
funny if when he rolled up a sleeve he
said welcome to the gun show it would
have been funny
derek says summit lol more like an abyss
yeah this is some kind of turning point
summit but it is really like a deep
deep trench jamal swift haven't seen you
in a while jamal says hi homie great to
see you
and david abel says worst voiceover guy
anyway
ever i guess you're probably referring
to one of our
uh one of one of our various callers
that we had
i do want to say thank you to sonia cody
who is new member number 35 today and
also uh j.p lauren who just grabbed a
twitch sub
and his new member number 36 we are
looking at opening the phone lines
we are 14 website members and twitch
subs away
from from doing it do i have any new
songs i don't think so
um i played i played the one that i have
i've got as you as you guys all know now
we have i have a centralized database of
all of the songs
and i can sort them by meme so for
example
uh we can sort so i've got like two
boner show ones
and then three collar songs one jessie
lee peterson
uh three different paula white songs one
rudy giuliani fart song
there's a bunch of massive dumps songs
i actually keep i keep all these things
oh actually i don't know that i've
played all of these but you know we take
it all very seriously imagine imagine a
job where you have a massive dumps
section uh let's see dj physics
massive dump song that seems interesting
let me take a look here where it is
this election was over and then they did
dumps they call them dumps
big massive dumps
[Music]
okay so we actually have played that one
i feel like there is something here we
haven't played before
officer akimov is that have i played
this one
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
oh this is genius extra points if you
can sample
trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it this is so good
please do it this is fantastic
this is a hot track
[Music]
big
big massive dumps
[Music]
ducks dumps dumps
dumps dumps right
[Music]
donald trump
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is
just
[Music]
dumps dumps
[Music]
tremendous amounts of water where the
water rushes out to sea
[Music]
anyway you get the idea so so you know i
maintain a database of all of these uh
different songs very very important
thing
uh to be doing as you can imagine uh if
we were to lose any of the
if we were to lose track of any of those
tracks
that would really be a tragedy that
would really be a tragedy
okay other streams coming up this week
uh i don't know um i don't know what
else we've so there's we're running up
against a couple of problems
one is that donald trump doesn't do
anything anymore in fact let's take a
look at his schedule
and you will see that he does not he
doesn't do stuff
um so today no public events scheduled
yesterday no public events scheduled
uh no public events scheduled a private
meeting with the secretary of defense
a private signing ceremony a private
cabinet meeting
nothing on last tuesday
lunch with pence and a private signing
last monday golf previous sunday
travel previous saturday nothing on
friday the 11th uh private lunch
on the 10th you know i mean he just
doesn't do anything anymore
and the biden team is absolutely
terrible
at telling us ahead of time what's going
on they often don't schedule events on
their youtube channel
until five minutes before the event is
scheduled to start so it's it's actually
just hard to keep track what i'm hoping
for
so here's the trajectory for the next
week if we get a kaylee magananny press
briefing or something from trump or
biden events i'll cover them
um we then are going to be there's no
show next week just bear that in mind no
show next week the show is off next week
no podcast no etc as you know
um january is going to start strong
because january 5th we have georgia
elections and i'm going to cover those
live january 6th we have the counting of
the electoral ballots in the house and
senate we will be covering that live
and then we'll have two weeks until the
inauguration which we will also be
covering live so there's some big events
coming um but a lot of these are just
kind of unpredictable
and i'm not i'm not doing anything next
week during our vacation so i may pop in
for some live streams if news breaks
but there will be no podcast and there
actually will be clips
next week because we've been holding
i've been holding back a strategic
reserve
of clips for the last three weeks so
that we're going to have some uh
some stuff publishing next week as well
chaka seki says
trump has so many private shows and
events that he might as well start his
own only fans
well said jacob ratner says will trump
run shadow presidency after
inauguration who knows
who knows and rusty lewis says sir i
love the
rusty lewis massive trump song okay
since rusty
is is asking for it let's look at the
rusty lewis
massive dump song just real quick
the biggest we've ever seen big massive
dump
coming in rapidly massive dumps
big massive dumps huge new
dumpsters coming
[Music]
this is disgusting wash your hands
we have a situation where we're looking
very strongly at sinks and showers
it's all quite extraordinary mr
president
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
really this is what i've been looking to
do for a long time
time for lesson massive dumps
okay so that's uh that's the track from
rusty lewis that is that is a very very
good one thank you
uh okay and then red rover says i
imagine biden team doesn't announce the
schedule
for safety from turd rump loons yeah i
don't think that's the case
joe biden is very well protected thanks
to
jonathan svenson who is new member
number 37
at joinpackman.com very much appreciate
that we are standing by if you can
believe it we just stumbled across this
we we are standing by for from a speech
at a
vile right wing event from the last
liberal liberal dave rubin
um we are standing by for that and if
people want the phone lines open that's
an
if don't feel obligated we are just 13
website members and subs away from
opening the phone lines actually thanks
to a donation by cornelia fenwinkel
via twitch we are now
five closer so we're actually now
at 42. okay so we may get phone lines
open it's up to you guys
uh i say we do it we're only eight away
but uh that that's really up to you and
for people asking
is it better to sign up on twitch or my
website
it is better on my website that's the
truth we you know
we keep almost every penny on my website
whereas all these other platforms are
taking slices
slices slices slices to quote uh
to quote andrew yang um
magnum satan has gifted another five
which puts us now at 47. oh wow we're
getting really close
it would be really crazy if we didn't
make it let's listen to a little bit of
this breitbart dude before dave rubin
any of you know anything about china no
deal gets done
like that unless it has the express
permission of the chinese communist
party
none of these people had expertise and
all of them got rich
and all of them are bidens and that
brings us to october the 14th
what the new york post put out the
report that hunter biden introduced the
corrupt
energy company burisma and its officials
to vice president joe biden
what if facebook did this story they
suppressed it
what did twitter do to this story they
locked people out of their accounts who
shared it
including the new york post we're
talking three weeks before an election
a major news these people are out of
their minds hundreds of years
locked out of their own account and
they're locked out of their own account
for two full weeks even though jack
dorsey acknowledged
in retrospect they didn't violate any
rules
and what did they call this story they
called it russian
disinformation it's like everything else
russian disinformation
washington post called it a russian
intelligence operation wikipedia
referred to it as russian interference
this is conspiracy website chief uh
alex marlow from breitbart accusing
others i guess
of conspiracies okay good all right
thanks to six more twitch subs we have
now
gotten to um 53
so as promised let's open the phone
lines as we wait a little bit for dave
rubin here if you want to talk to me go
to davidpakman.com
discord get in the waiting lobby
waiting lobby change your nickname
to location colon name and i will pick
up
on some calls okay very very easy
davidpakman.com
discord let's go first to
jack from antwerp now is that antwerp
belgium
yes that's i'm from belgium that's uh
why the be is
uh i love antwerp i've been to antwerp
it's fantastic
well nice well that's awesome um
oh hello david um let me see if you take
my
michael um
i guess basically i mean i i often think
about when uh
i'm gonna get on and i can ask questions
and i get a lot of questions in my head
but now i'm a bit lost um
i guess what i once i
have this problem i guess i hope you can
help me
uh oh okay yeah so
i want to do more basically for
the leftist movement i guess in my
country
and in my area because uh
well i'm scared that next election the
right-wing parties are going to get way
more votes than they thought this time
and maybe a mighty
majority and are going to take more
power in government
and such um and i'm already kind of
in in local politics and i try to
convince people and talk to them when i
can but i'm
i'm kind of at a loss as to how to do
more i mean can i
should i go make posters or like
become a public figure like you are
or um listen uh i mean you know i
i think someone who lives in belgium may
be better suited to tell you the best
way to get involved in politics in
belgium
uh uh generally speaking i'm very
concerned about some of these
nationalist right-wing movements in
europe but
i i would really look to someone in
belgium who would be far better suited
than me i think
to tell you yeah that's that's probably
that's probably right stuff like
um you know trump talks a lot about
antifa
in belgium uh well in europe and fifa
isn't
that big thing i mean i've looked at
this as an alternative as needed to take
action and do something against those
people but
it's very different as in the us i guess
yeah
yeah i don't know about the presence of
antifa in belgium jack but i think
i would look to left-wing belgian groups
that would be the way to go
i think because uh they they would know
far more than i do
jack from antwerp i'm gonna let you go
uh we're gonna listen very very actually
let's take another call or two and then
we'll listen to a little bit of dave
dave rubin i think this will be pretty
funny um but
first let's go to uh
where do we want to go there's a lot of
people wanting to talk
now let's go to matt f from upstate new
york
matt what's going on hey can you hear me
yes i can
hey big fan of the show um i have two
questions
please um it's kind of a two-part
question so i'll ask
um the first part first that i like that
idea actually you know what
do they have to go in that order um
actually i guess it kind of can go as
one big question so i'll just ask it
beautiful so do you think it's realistic
to win both of the georgia senate seats
because historically you know it's very
difficult
to win races versus incumbents
and if the democrats take both seats do
you think that there's a chance that
a few biden's cabinet picks um i guess
off the top of my head
um near tandon still don't get confirmed
due to opposition from the left
um you know in bernie sanders and
elizabeth warren
um i that i don't know about that second
i don't i don't uh and anticipate i
think that biden's gonna get
essentially everybody confirmed that
that's that's the first and foremost
i think that the way i would assess it
is each of the democratic challengers in
georgia
has a 48 chance of winning so
i think if the question is what are the
odds they both win
i think it's a you know we're just doing
the math here it's 0.48
times 0.48 which works out to what it's
got to be about 23
or something like that yeah i guess that
was more of my
my question because i i know you had a
um
a video about polling yes you know
obviously obviously you can't trust
the polling because especially in this
race it's so close yeah i think it's
irrelevant in other words
this is the one race there's no it's not
like oh how much time do we put into
these versus others these are the two
races these are the two races
it's probably close they're relevant in
general because
regardless of the margin of error or
projected winners i think it tends to
favor
the people that are losing in the polls
it generates more turnout
and i also believe that you know if a
candidate's
projected to win you know by like six
seven points
then the members of that party are less
likely to
vote and therefore the turnout isn't um
well that's trump's argument
trump says that that that's how you
suppress turnout you know and and i
don't know
i mean listen it's just close and when
it's a few points
it's unlikely to suppress turnout one
way or the other is my opinion
all right unless he suppresses turnout
from his own um voter base which is
looking like it's gonna do at least to
an extent
they may be doing that they maybe
there's no question that they may
suppress by especially also by claiming
you know it's rigged
um all right matthew thank you so much i
appreciate the call i want to say one
more thing
um i was a poll worker in this year's
election and i can confirm there are no
massive dumps there were no dumps okay
that's important not even
i live in upstate new york too so very
very rural very conservative
and if there were dumps there you would
know because of your location
correct okay very good all right matthew
thank you so much
let's listen to dave rubin now
addressing a right-wing crowd
the last liberal dave rubin so when i
tell you guys
that you are protesting in the most
beautiful freaking way possible right
now you really are
i guess he's praising people for having
an event during a pandemic
i'm telling you guys the the generations
before you that have done a ton of good
right we've
we've generated wars against real nazis
not imaginary nazis right we've done
we've expanded freedoms right we've
expanded freedoms for women and for
black people and for gay people and all
of these things that america has done it
and it's this place no cheering for that
with this crowd silent crowd
is this this idea that everyone can come
from every walk of earth
from whatever religion whatever region
whatever nationality whatever skin color
we can all come to this magical place
and make it better and yet right now you
guys
18 20 22 years old it's on you to fix
this thing
all right let's listen uh let's listen
to let's see if we can talk to a
just a couple of other people um let's
go to brian from gainesville
gainesville georgia now there's also a
gainesville in florida right
hey david can you hear me yes i can yes
so google does that a lot i
have to specify gainesville georgia all
the time because it's mixed up with
gainesville florida
so my question to you is um
should joe biden on day one
uh invoke i believe it's the emergencies
act of 1975.
um does joe biden i
i guess i'm wondering if he has the
authority to declare climate change and
national authority
a national emergency under that act i
don't know
but what would be achieved but what do
you want him to achieve
by so doing
uh well
i want to see well i want to see the
federal government pivot more
toward doing what it can to you know
obviously tamp down on carbon emissions
um uh uh
maybe implementing some aspects of
uh what has been proposed in the green
new deal and do you think that
that is more likely to happen i think
that's going to depend more on whether
the the senate is one then whether joe
biden can use a 1973
emergencies law to declare climate
uh an emergency i think it's more about
the senate
right right yeah
what do you think about that uh
well i
um i think i agree and um
i can say for myself you know i live in
georgia so
um i just checked on my ballot and it
was
um it was received so hopefully uh
you know hopefully i can help you know
make somewhat of a difference and
getting hopefully getting two democratic
senators elected here
let's do it we'll be covering it good
luck down there yeah
thank you all right very good um taking
some calls at davidpakman.com
discord seeing who is uh who is who is
on
let's go to is it macclesfield england i
don't even have a name i have
almost no information about this caller
hello caller from macclesfield england
hello can you hear me
yeah how how is it pronounced what's the
name of the place you're in yeah it's
it's macclesfield in england here oh
okay and what's your name
my name's elliot it does say at the end
but i think it's just pushed off i think
it's all
i think macclesfield england is so many
characters i couldn't even see your name
yeah sorry about that no problem so so
what's happening
um well i'm just keeping up to date with
uh with your politics more than my own
right i said my own i mean english um
sure
but it's um yeah it's pretty
pretty crazy times um it feels like
in politics now you can stand up there
um lie as much as you want and then
if you can convince enough people you
can get into power and it seems like
a pretty flawed system um yeah it seems
to be working
for a lot of people in a lot of parts of
the world right now
yeah it seems like that's what happened
in the uk for our recent election
because it just makes no sense the way
the country's going
and the the things that certain people
vote for you know that they're just
just inherently and not you know a
morally nice person
um and it kind of it confuses me how
politics is that way i mean
i've not followed politics for many
years um but
i don't know it's just uh it's pretty
crazy um
now are you are you um are you brutally
locked down
under lock and key thanks to extreme
socialist boris johnson
um not a hundred percent know i'm it's a
tier system now tier system now
and i'm in a tier three um but london
just went to tier 4 the other day and
my girlfriend's brother um was in london
and he had to quickly get on a train and
get out there as fast as he could
so he could get out and get to his
brother's house for christmas
now when we when we're talking about
being locked down grocery stores are
open right you can go out and go to a
grocery store
yes um hardware stores are open sort of
like you know generic places where you
could go and get either gift wrap or a
hammer
yeah yeah it seems to be that most
places like that are also open at the
moment um
are restaurants open for what we call
take out and i believe you call take
away
yes yes those are open they're also open
for sitting in as well
and now wait a second so you guys are
quote locked down but
restaurants are open for indoor dining
oh yeah yeah basically the the stupid
rule is
you can go and you can drink alcohol if
you're eating a meal
but you can't drink alcohol if you're
not um
but you can still go out but you're not
supposed to um and it's basically all
these mixed messages that no one's
following
the good thing is a lot a lot of people
are wearing masks now but
it's not everyone now what are is it
stricter if you're in a tier 4
area yes yes but that's only just come
into play um in london so i don't
actually know the full
details about tier four i think it's
just you're not supposed to go out
unless you are
shopping i think is not being able to
drink unless you're eating fascism in
your mind
no i think it's a way to stop people
getting too rowdy
i kind of agree with it i mean i'm not a
big drinker myself so it's not bothering
me
um but you know when people get drunk
you know you're hugging everyone you see
it doesn't matter if you know them or
not you'll hug them
so i think it's wise to stop people
drinking yeah would you be able
theoretically to go and get go to a chip
shop and get 10 beers
and some chips uh no
probably not from a chip shop but
you could go to a restaurant with your
friends and order a a pint of beer each
all right but that's probably yeah last
question do you believe that you guys
need a national referendum on
eliminating mushy peas
no it doesn't bother me i don't eat
mushy peas but
i'm in the mindset that if you like it
go for it you're more of a libertarian
where you don't want to have you don't
you don't have to have it yourself but
you're okay with it being legal
yeah of course yeah beautiful beautiful
all right my friend thank you i
appreciate the call
no problem thank you for your time all
right there it is uh let's listen to
just a few more minutes of dave ruben
here then we'll take a couple more calls
align his cage like the more that these
things collapse
the more that we're all going to go into
our ideological echo chambers right the
more that you guys are going to go all
right well i'll watch
i'll watch shapiro and i'll watch reuben
and whatever it is on this side and i'm
not even going to pay attention there's
pay a little attention to what they're
doing pay a little attention to what
they're doing
and know that some of this is just a
little bit of a of a psychological
makeup sometimes there may be a little
more sensitive than you might be
sometimes
psychologist dave rubin with huge ideas
let's go next to silvia stefaniak
from portugal is that right sylvia
hello sylvia
sylvia
hi silvia from portugal
oh boy all right that's too bad let's
listen to this question coming in
everybody a refugee from san francisco
why does no one have masks over their
face they're leaving my state in mass
numbers specifically liberals and they
are going to red states
but they are not understanding that the
left-leaning policies that they voted
for
were responsible for ruining their home
state and they're bringing those to
other states
i've tried talking to many people about
this issue but they are reluctant to
face it this kid's got upper management
written all over them they actually
contributed to it back home in
california
and how they're bringing it elsewhere
what can i and other californians do
well yeah great question and as a guy
that lives in la i hear you man i hear
you
listen first off if you live in a red
state you should build a wall i want to
be very clear about that
oh my god this is so stupid it's uh it's
actually painful i think i'm gonna need
some kind of treatment after this
because it's so dumb
let's go next to uh daniel from
california daniel from california it's
also boring right right daniel
oh uh way more boring than your show
thank you
um so i'm a member from the legal
discount days okay youtube back when it
was like 10
off your your membership would pass
scrutiny even under a fascistic
dictatorship
i would not have to seek a pardon that's
for sure beautiful
so if trump becomes
a political liability for republicans
and the politicians start to distance
themselves from
trump i don't think they should be let
off
that easy because they have supported
and enabled trump's transgressions
against this country right from the
operation of
families to mishandling mishandling of
covid
to you know um uh
his current coup if we call it that i
agree with you and
i want to know what you think of this
idea if
politicians on the left started
referring to
uh the republican party as trump's party
as a way to try to tie
you know republicans to to trump uh i
don't know that that'll be that
effective but i think the point you're
making is a good one which is
the repub republicans are getting ready
if trump just fades away on january 20th
all these republicans will go back to
sort of pretending trump didn't happen
and saying we've got to deal with the
debt we've got to deal with the debt
like
they will go right back to what they
were before donald trump
and and try to avoid all consequences
for their either
explicit or implicit support of trump or
indifference to trump this entire time
there's no doubt whatsoever
and i've been saying for a while they
need to be held accountable will they be
i don't know but my my belief is they
will probably get away with it
i see well if you can make a clip of you
know maybe how we can
um or how democratic politicians really
can
make it so they don't get away with it
yeah would be helpful
let me i will look into that and i will
report back okay thank you and
one last thing i did uh fill out the
contact form
about an exchange i had with sam cedar
of
multi-panel backdrop fame okay and i
don't know if you have time you could
look at that
when when was that probably three weeks
ago i was about to defund the police
slogan i think sam had a lot of good
things to say
about it that mirrors your analysis
somewhat
okay but it's a little a little
different yeah all right i will check it
out thank you that contact form gets
used a lot you know right right yeah
yeah a lot of subs a lot of youtube subs
i don't know if they're real
but right but i ain't well the the thing
about fake youtube subscribers is they
don't email you
right right all right thank you
appreciate it very
very much let's listen to the next
question being posed here mentality of
hey i'm a little bit liberal on this
side i'm a little bit conservative on
this side
but with the growing division of a lot
of the conservatives i've seen today
like how can i integrate my centrism to
get people to be more
like not divided so much like for the
left or right
and even within the right yeah it's a
good question you know i'm the new guy
on the right so
you know when i see these divisions that
i hear some of you guys talking about
okay so we've got
the more traditional conservatives let's
say we've got the more libertarian side
of it
and whatever else you want to whittle it
down to to me that's great because i
know you guys are all in this room right
now that that is fantastic
right there are believers in this room
there are not this is really dumb hey um
jesse james in twitch chat says that sam
cedar has been
using an alpha male mashup to troll me
that sounds funny if someone can email
me that through my website
contact form i would very much like to
see that all right my friends i'm glad
we were able to take some calls i'm not
going to be able to take any more today
um i would uh very much look forward to
seeing you guys
later this week we saw joe biden get his
vaccine we saw everything happen
all right so make sure if you're
watching on youtube hit that subscribe
button it's free we're at 1.2 million
subscribers if you can believe it
and of course if you're watching on
twitch make sure to follow me we are
working our way towards our first
100 000 twitch subs
i will hopefully see everybody tomorrow